hides word back here on the show how are
you hi I'm rich now first let me tell
you I appreciate that opportunity and I
got a chance to meet George Clooney up
close in person and uh and I had a blast
well I appreciate the opportunity for
going out there on the red carpet or an
Oscar but Clooney's a Bengals fan no
Heinz I know but this was right after
the time there's a couple of years after
TJ Houshmandzadeh who by the way I saw
in Cincinnati last week with Chad
Johnson they were all there he wiped his
feet on a Terrible Towel right I think
that happened well you got the damn and
playoffs we get to the Super Bowl
oh we got the last laugh you did you did
so what do you think of the Steelers now
just two games in hinds what do you what
do you make of them because they it
hasn't seemed to be very seamless and
Le'Veon Bell has not gotten anything
going on after his holdout yeah you
can't just take off football and submit
the whole training camp and thinking you
just going to come into the game and
just dominate just doesn't happen that
way
but I just think it takes time I mean
you have the skill it's played the best
football yeah no I don't think so
and I'll be no team is really playing
the best football but you know finding
ways to win games and everybody starting
to get acclimated I think martavis
Bryant I'm taking a whole year all
because of suspension coming back he's
starting to get his feet wet a little
bit he's bigger he's stronger he's
faster and I like the presence of
juniors yeah she was doing the flight
along with Eli Rockies and big then he
planted a different level you know I
wasn't you know I was I'm kind of India
the guys now because the way you command
to all fans I mean I played defense
limiting his drones was a heavy snowfall
25 times again don't turn the ball over
to tend the ball off his drone better
and let let our defense play good
defense and that was our formula for
success and now how things have changed
I mean they got weapons all over the
field and it's kind of fun to see so I
really think you know when they come
into it all together and everybody mesh
well together it's all about the
chemistry and building that foundation
to be fun well I mean Hines Ward joining
me here on the show I remember the
conversation after Bill Cowher retired
and went into the paparazzi Hines is
that obviously leaving Mike Tomlin out
of it that just a change of voice was
important for Ben because of the fact
that he felt he was being called a game
manager and he could do more the fact
that another coach who didn't draft him
and wasn't there for the aches and pains
and growing pains or to put I guess in a
way some form of damper on his playbook
that that meant a big world of
difference for Big Ben I remember that
was a conversation was that accurate to
come in the passing league game caters
for all things you can't touch the
receivers anymore across the middle and
everything about protecting the
quarterback and that really wasn't the
case
back then we had Baltimore I mean the
key to success was running the ball and
playing great defense and now James
you're just swinging it all over the
place but I think that's just a
maturation process for Big Ben of where
he was and the first came into the
league worse now
he's calling his own play you know where
everyone has a notice times when I play
with Ben and you know the only new one
or few had and now I know what everyone
he's putting guys in one certain
position so just to see his you know his
maturation process
of him getting better year in and year
out I just think it's phenomenal he is a
deathly grumpy one then we quarterback
and one thing that you can also do in
the NFL Hines is a receivers can't come
back and and and block they can't hit
somebody anymore you know why because
you did it - well I never thought you
were dirty but people definitely needed
their head on a swivel around Hans ward
there's no question about that
no I know I know so do you think it's a
softer game now Hans I mean because I
understand what the leaders trying to do
is try not you know clean the game up a
little bit make it safer for guys you
know what happened I mean now there's
more knowledge about concussions and
things like that shopping the leaders
doing a great job of kind of cleaning up
some of things in that area to help
protect the players but still the game
of football you have two grown men
running colliding with each other and
forcing your brain is going to shake you
know and everyone and you know I really
can't explain you know the cause of it
but until the doctors can give guys a
definite answer say okay CTE is it play
football you see geez you won't wear
patches hippie until the doctors tell us
that you know I just think God's going
to continue to play the game and knowing
that they're putting their livelihood
later on down the road a couple more
minutes left here with Hines Ward
courtesy of FedEx here on the Rich Eisen
show what's your favorite Dan Rooney
story Hines give me a good story about
the late Stephen
when I got there we had virgin camp and
I remember coming into building you know
he he felt small batches they're like
you know you blow on he's just gonna
like fall over so when I shook his hand
I gently shook his hand and he said no I
thought that over he said like oh my
hand you need a real handshake custom
and in his eye he talked to me and I was
like man it was like a father figure
that I never had taught me
appreciation of value of a handshake is
the ownership like the running pants are
pants right hand is already component to
a handshake so yeah your hand just fits
awesome because he's taken so many hands
over this time that its anus kind of it
kind of kind of just molded into a nice
firm handshake you sure it wasn't great
grabbing the look you sure it wasn't
grabbing the Lombardi Trophy could have
been that - that's nice there was a nice
moment yesterday in Pittsburgh so what
do you think about last football
question for you here Heinz the the
Steelers Super Bowl chances I mean how
legit are they knowing that you see
there's Brady you see what the Raiders
look like the Chiefs have certainly put
their hat in this AFC ring here and then
there might be some surprise team that
catches fire and then the Ravens are
sitting there at to know what do you
think you're playing at home rather than
on the road down the road I just think I
like the a couple additions that they
put into secondary because I've always
felt like Pittsburgh second area was the
reason with Connor you know they were
lacking the playmakers that enabled
answer to make it to the next level play
the Super Bowl but I like what what
Hayden brings to the table to go along
with all these bands and
gamespot stuff like that and and i like
our young nucleus linebackers i think
now they're starting to come into their
own
you know typically we can hold up and
good courses can get home-field
advantage
Wow I think I got a great chance of
making and so what are you doing with
the FedEx junior business challenge
finals on Wednesday in Atlanta at the
PGA Tour Championship of all places to
finds what are you doing new the new
program called FedEx cares it's a global
giving initiative where FedEx is
investing 200 million dollars in over
200 communities around the world by the
year 2020 and so I'll be at the Tour
Championship Wednesday it's kind of
basically like Shark Tank
I mean well we're evaluating small
businesses for young high school
students and aware of it of that
competition is five teams that get a
chance to win seventy-five thousand
dollars donations from FedEx so I'm
super excited to kind of be there to see
our young generation startup small
businesses and stuff like that you know
because you know small businesses are
down now because all the Millennials
they trying to make their money on
podcast and in social media stuff like
that you know I just think it's cool to
see high school kids come together and
create a small business plans and you
know they can go out and prevent it well
me and for the judges are be judging the
contest and hopefully they can get
things started
I'm super excited to be a part of it and
you know it's down here in East Lake in
Atlanta those right in my backyard
though intense honored to be a part of
it I can't look Hines thanks for the
call when you're out here in Los Angeles
love to have you in studio love to hang
out
anytime anytime RIT you got it at time
to work the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what it catches